oh boy here we go ladies and gentlemen
canoco phillips a 100 plus billion oil
producer one of the largest oil
producers in the world has officially
announced that they are mining bitcoin
here within the united states kanoko
phillips is running the bakken bitcoin
pilot project this is using the oil that
is coming out of the ground to actually
mine bitcoin now as we know bitcoin is
the most decentralized secure computing
network in the world and bitcoin miners
are responsible for securing that
network there's over 40 million dollars
being paid out every single day right
now to those bitcoin miners in exchange
for them securing the network and of
course if you are an energy producer
this is one of the most profitable ways
for you to monetize your energy
production and so conoco phillips that
100 plus billion oil producer they're
not only in the game they've been in the
game for a while they're just now
publicly talking about it this is
important because they're the first
major oil producer to admit that they
are mining bitcoin that they're mining
bitcoin within the united states and it
is a signal to the market that every
single oil producer is going to start to
mine bitcoin that's true of both
us-based entities and also international
entities as well everyone from aramco to
exxon mobil all the way through the
industry every single oil producer is
going to be mining bitcoin because it is
the most profitable use of their energy
the bitcoin network is going to get more
secure it's going to get more
decentralized and it is going to become
more valuable over time this is all
inevitable and now that we have conoco
phillips admitting that they are mining
bitcoin in the u.s buckle up baby the
oil producers are on the way they're all
going to be mining bitcoin and i can't
wait to see how quickly this is going to
happen hey you did you like this video
great we make five of them a day and
post them here on this channel make sure
you subscribe like the video and see you
next time